well you know eight news now and our
next star sister stations are teaming up
to raise money to provide meals for one
million people in need with our super
bowl of caring now you can do so by
donating to three square food bank which
serves all four counties right here in
southern nevada kirsten joyce reports on
the need this year
the trend is heading in the right
direction three square food bank's kate
hibbard gaines says right now about 363
thousand people in southern nevada are
food insecure meaning one in six adults
doesn't know where their next meal is
coming from and that includes one in
four children to put that into
perspective that's all of henderson and
boulder city combined pretty big number
and while it significantly dropped from
440 000 individuals since the height of
the pandemic when there were dozens of
emergency drive through distribution
centers it's still not at pre-pandemic
levels rent is definitely having to pay
for those hard things health care costs
are going up everything sort of seems to
be going up folks are having to make
tough decisions whether or not to pay
the rent medical expenses or to put
groceries on the table that's where
three square food bank comes into the
picture to make sure families can have a
little bit of relief with its
collaborative charitable food network
donations made to three square food bank
for the remainder of this month and
especially through next our super bowl
of caring will have an incredible effect
we have a match that's happening right
now through the end of the year so
for every dollar you donate that can
normally turn into three meals it can
now become six meals which will have
such a tremendous impact
and remember you can help out three
square foot bank by clicking on the qr
code on the screen by putting your
smartphone right up against that code
you can also find other charities in the
valley on tackle the hunger map and it
will count towards the super bowl of
caring goal